[Music]
in inappropriate news planetary I just
saw the corns on his feet submitted by
crazy 88 [ __ ] tongue hustle oh I know
from kills oh yeah I don't know look
what you did
oh it's a band that band won't kill bill
right it's the ninjas managers thought
that was come for us with my death of a
female soccer star was asked if she
knows how to twerk what setting while
accepting a prestigious award
what is it cuz she did a viral twerking
video no maybe she looks good for soccer
so she got a fat ass can we see the
evidence yeah yeah if she had a flat ass
I'd be very offended like why would they
sexually harass her lap no but white
girls always think they can't work with
no ass like Miley Cyrus has zero ass
zero
his girlfriend's a white girl and she
got ass today I know but I'm saying you
talking about white girls with no yeah
if you had no Ashley shouldn't be
twerking okay then it's then that's the
statement that right nomads don't work
this way I have somebody I say if I say
do you think Cameron Diaz has a nice ass
no and if they say yes then I know they
don't know what ass is exactly because
if Cameron Diaz a nice ass what's
beyonce and you know what's her name is
a tennis player like that like what
Serena Serena any other that's ash you
know Jennifer Lopez got you know yes you
got that Cameron Diaz is a nice ass
let's Bob our TV now that's a whole
different category like it's like a
tractor-trailer it's still ass
compared to Noah it is absolutely but
that's like a genetically modified
prestigious a war like you guys were
getting our podcast award walking yeah
of course it says it's a little
inappropriate
Twitter's like be the worst spot for
this because literally Miley Cyrus had
like a promo for this Sh and her butt
and then case let's be shook and then
somebody wrote what does chic mean I
can't cuz so [ __ ] flat which is so
true yeah and she makes working famous
oh yeah that's weird dude salta soccer
star her name is ADA her burg she's
Norwegian she's 23 years old she was
nice you look you had me at Norwegian
gonna be hot like white sauce blender
well you're describing it's like a
modeling profile you giving this right
you know clarify okay so she was a very
first woman to win the Ballon D or which
is a super prestigious award with the
first human woman a woman wore for
animals horses issues we're gonna see
her at all for the prior winners like
title award football or soccer we know
it I thought yeah I get it
football SUT I don't know they were so
into twerking in France so this DJ he's
a French DJ named Martin Solveig oh I
know hey well now we're getting more of
the founder it's not like the presenter
was like that's what I pictured yeah
yeah DJ did this like okay it's not that
bad
I pictured a guy this is right he was
like and the award goes to hey baby can
you twerk hey you know come on I would
have been the best this is
and her award this year was the first
year that they added like a women's
category for this award
so it's a big deal she won it this is
the DJ [ __ ] him up dude I like her too
did he just ask her and now she's mad
she's like the [ __ ] all you makes
waffles whatever you're gonna see her
reaction he's asking her you know it's
good you said - work it work it that was
the video she looks pissed I would be
pissed yeah like I just received this
prestigious inappropriate time the whole
presentation thing and then this was
like him talking to her and pretty much
saying like come on baby let me see if
you get one you didn't get it it's like
being inducted into the Hall of Fame and
they're just asking for something else
stupid so this is his statement he says
I want to publicly apologize for any
misunderstanding that came from
yesterday's exchange between myself and
ADA her Berg during the Milan day or
ceremony I acknowledge that it was in
poor taste and I am deeply sorry for my
mistake to add context to the incident I
was asked to prepare a song for each
winner and would dance with each
recipient after their award was
presented the clips circulating on
social media does not reflect the whole
situation moments after I made the
remark we went on to dance together to
Frank Sinatra's fly me to the moon the
twerking comment was used in contrast to
the song I had prepared for her however
this sentiment was misunderstood and has
sadly caused effect that makes sense
immediately apologize to keep prepping
for a Joe a joke
upset yeah that's what happens with non
comedians how to do jokes though the
real issue here is that the social
justice warriors took this out of
context play that little part the way
what we just saw does look extremely
enterprise it was taken out of context
let's defend it to you I know but she
wasn't but what I'm saying he does
something she's always a fan about it
just went like this to him but we know
we can see that this is not as serious
as but if I only show that moment all
yeah it's gonna look like you did
something completely wrong yeah I take
offense to that
that's what happened to me recently - on
my Instagram like I there was like an
ongoing joke that we have with this food
series and then this one girl got super
offended about this comment that I made
and then she didn't watch the whole
thing and then she just went off with it
what were you talk was she offended that
you don't get fans and Tim does it nice
way to call him out no cuz there's at
the inside joke right yeah in that case
to like I just her feelings were so hurt
you know I was like okay well I can't
change the fact that your feelings are
hurt you if you don't get the joke it's
understand what was it what was it oh I
called her a loose woman and so like it
was the joke was that I make fun of
everybody on the show just because they
don't recognize Who I am so in the Adder
who you are it doesn't matter right so
it's supposed to be in stark contrast
but she looks like a regular girl so if
you weren't like a hooker it wouldn't be
funny right it's not a funny joke yeah
so it's funny because she looks like a
normal girl yeah you know and so for her
she's just like I can't believe she made
it into a gender issue thing she goes oh
exactly and so that's why I got like how
was explained to me was because she
doesn't understand the joke it becomes
she becomes the butt of the joke so I'm
like fine it makes it even follow I'll
apologize to you because your feelings
were hurt and if you don't understand it
I understand so I still apologize
because she felt that so I was like
that's cool yeah yeah she could still be
stupid yeah she can still be offending
the Ness completely her right so I you
know I felt bad because she didn't
understand it and she felt that she was
the butt of the joke then I kind of felt
a little bad and that's how my mom
explained it to me too so I was like I
don't mind people being offended yeah
it's like I just don't appreciate how
they have to evolve everyone else in it
yeah yeah yeah that's why I got mad
because it's a you're offended [ __ ] you
okay that's your thing yeah you know if
you want to send some private message
and be like hey I was offended by this
then you could take the time to be like
oh I didn't know that but when you make
it out to be like everyone has to know
then [ __ ] you because you're just doing
that for attention yeah I'm offended
well you're offended too right what
happened to me conversely there was
another girl that was next to her right
and she wrote about she goes hey like I
get it's just a jokes for the show but I
don't like the way people are
approaching me oh oh cool and we ended
it like that with her but the other one
exactly make it into a gender and that's
why I got mad because it was like you
know like there's actual like issues
with gender in this country or you can't
just use that just because I benefits
you yeah yeah yeah
that's why I got mad yes I totally agree
like I'll put it out there though I
still apologize I told if I see you in
person
I'll apologize to you in person too
because I don't want you to walk away
feeling offended yes like you don't
understand so you want to put like some
kind of extra thing on it is what I hate
what she was doing was questioning your
intentions yes actually defining your
intent yes and that's not fair
yeah that's not fair it's like if you
say a joke and somebody takes offense
that's their translation exactly so oh
and which is fair but then you can't say
that that's what I meant yes exactly you
just took it that way so if I'm gonna be
like oh okay maybe I need to be more
clear about my joke yeah
oh sorry that you didn't understand that
I didn't mean that yeah but you also see
that side of a tutor people that don't
see that side can go [ __ ] themselves I
think that's the whole that's a comic
I'm saying you can go [ __ ] yourself if
you think are you gonna determine my
intentions because of your narrow
thinking yeah translate that
[ __ ] yeah I think that's the
whole thing now is just this is what I
perceive but that's fact and I'm gonna
attack you for it because you need to
change and so this is what I do now
instead of arguing with them I say did I
hurt your feelings that's what I'm
saying
it's still valid for you to be like oh
I'm sorry yeah 100% it's like oh I'm
sorry but at the same time it's like I
need to also hear some acknowledgement
that it's like oh why I knew could they
say like I know you didn't mean this but
this is how I felt about it
well saying okay yeah that's a hundred
possesses sound like a you problem
yeah I mean because her friend
understood that part that means that it
was clearly communicated so it's a
personal issue right right so it's not
that it was a joke what in itself was
executed you just didn't like it that's
okay
and that's okay that's okay but don't
put it out there as if like all of a
sudden now will you hate women yeah and
that's what it came out she said it's
like okay totally go the David doesn't
hate women though that means they didn't
take a class in conflict resolution yeah
I missed cool though like I said like if
you watch this lady like I said it might
see you in person I'm apologized to
because you felt terrible I felt bad too
because of how I handle it like I should
have been more comedic about it but
they're not kind of went off rails yeah
I mean just because
yeah we get that feeling because someone
has taken what you've said out of
context and they put their own yeah
they're questioning your intentions and
morals and all that just because they
took it a certain way yeah it's like yes
to what people do they don't take
personal responsibility for their own
ignorance I mean being a stand-up comic
and how things have changed so rapidly
throughout the past several years do you
feel like a huge shift in comedians
being like more aware of what they're
saying and being kissed I think he was
used to be more thoughtful as the word
yeah yes before it was like The Comedy
room was like anything go well I mean I
still there's still a school thought
that anything should go because the
people listening you have to you know
look at what you're saying and be like
understand the context understand that
yes as a art form and it's it's a time
and place yeah it's a type of place but
because things are out in public you
know so now it's public consumption and
they're out on the internet or that now
it's like well now you you know you
might be offending a group of people you
know before it's like just in the club
you're fine you know you know what
you're getting when you get to go to a
comedy club but now things are like
being put out in public you can't take
snippets of a set you know like there's
things that led up to certain jokes that
ease the crowd into this certain type of
mindset when people do a full set and
people don't get that too you know
well what happens is people are smug I
think like the especially the left
liberal liberal people are smug and then
they they talk down to you yeah if you
make a joke about something they want to
give you the history of well you know
you make it Winston Churchill reference
in the name do they want to give you a
history like what do you know that he
did dis dis dis and this and you're like
wait you don't get the context of what
I'm saying right here in this situation
you really think that I'm going that
deep into it and that's why you know
that's why Trump's in office office
because the left side is so like elitist
and smug yeah and arrogant yeah and then
the regular people are just like I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
this guy there's just like keeping it
simple I know you know I'm here and
that's what happens in comedy that's why
it's like the left like you know it's
liberal
feminists and these people that like
don't want to have a conversation mm-hmm
they just want to attack right you know
there's different types you know yeah
but to me to movement I'm not like I
want a female to talk to me about it to
be like you know because when you see
all this stuff happen as a guy like even
with this thing with the twerking thing
if it was like even more inappropriate
you know as a guy we don't have anything
equivalent so we don't understand so
that I need a woman to be like well this
is this is how it is but yeah you have a
faction of feminists who don't want to
do that they just want to tear this [ __ ]
down it's just full of rage and anger
and there's no logic behind it yeah
there's no we gotta converse we got to
talk about there's a lot of men that are
open to listen and understand we want a
discussion but I know we just don't
understand is the main thing we just
don't you know and I always tell guys
it's not equivalent we don't have
anything equivalent to that's why you
know we just we're just weave harder to
understand when you don't experience it
yeah yeah yeah and it's nothing you know
how can we experience it you know
[Music]